[Musique]
nous sommes ici sur le site du collège
de la ville des bambous laponie est un
système qui permet l'élevage des
poissons et la culture des plantes dans
un système fermé les déchets des
poissons vont être récupérés par la
pompe avec l'eau il va être envoyée au
bio filtre le biofiltre à l'intérieur
duquel il ya des bactéries qui vont
transformer les déchets des poissons en
nitrates qui vont être ensuite envoyées
sur le bac à plante les plants à l'aide
de leurs racines vont pouvoir récupérer
ces nitrates et croître
puis elles vont nettoyer l'eau la dame
soit l'auto l'ex oui je peux y aller
mais tu reviens vite bien pour la
semaine prochaine vous allez me
présenter ses travaux à l'oral vous
pouvez maintenant ranger vos affaires et
je vous souhaite une bonne semaine à
eysines
[Musique]
ça
comme ça
les phares en fait une chanson j'ai pas
eu lieu
ichou
qu'est ce qui t'arrive et l escalier aïe
ça tu faire mal ça russe accorde
je me souviens quand j'étais petit j'ai
sauté dormir parce que je voulais faire
comme les agents secrets
sauf que je me suis ratée et je me suis
retrouvé avec un bras cassé ça alors un
vrai casse cou pour elle un peu bizarre
mon histoire non non au contraire c'est
très marrant et aussi merci merci
pourquoi pour ta confiance et bien merci
pour ta compagnie c'est très gentil de
venir avec moi mes amis ils ne voulaient
pas venir parce qu'elles ont un faute
d'ascenseur à cause d'un film d'horreur
qu'on a regardé ensemble
ben c'est avec plaisir ok alors à plus
oui à +16 on arrive mais je prend son
sac alors à la rançon et par vous faut
qu'on retrouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon d'accord c'est la non mais vous
n'aurez pas les bois se doit d'amener
16,3 me sens pas senti comme ça non
excusez-moi
on aimerait là vous poser une question
s'il vous plaît oui quoi fait référence
au fait ça à la nikon est témoin d'un
mouton et appels voix ça dehors
non je pense de votre âme il est parti
ce matin il n'est jamais revenu pour
gagner à bâle a battu voilà bah si les
parties gala il abbas à l'onu on s'en
rend pas plus avec les toilettes mais
oui on avait dû passer aux toilettes
[Musique]
ah ah
ban
[Musique]
bon on fait quoi tu vois à l'ubs à 100 m
ouais
[Musique]
et regardez là bas ne serait pas moins
cette façon par hasard oui c'est le
passé vincent soir c'est lui qui lui
avait donné plus et le cac également
faire ah oui je me souviens jours
au fait la
oui en fait c'est vincent partie on
il introduit mais non c'est pas possible
je rappelle toi allez venez on va le
chercher aurait téléphoné
[Musique]
non mais vous inquiétez pas j'ai appelé
la vie scolaire pour faire le point et
auquel cas on y sert à date retour chez
lui
[Musique]
bon là j'ai appuyé tout connaître de
madame frontale pas le choix non moi je
pense qu'il est en dehors du collège
oui mais où ba ba manguy hawass est bon
en plus c'est calme est alors réduit non
[Musique]
bakou
salut on ira là-bas ça va vous appeler
non en fait on sait pas où il est
vincent vous l'auriez pas vu du cosy 18
300 cas de notre classe
bizarre non ah si si il n'etait pas
compagnie
oui c'est dingue on n'avait jamais vu
avant de qui vous parlez de 100 ans
leurs classes à gattières qui est avec
le grand maître là oui il a fait
rencontrer s'installe g à le modep a
demandé à ce que ce faire il au snack
il peut peut-être vous aider salut sa
vie sa voix dit tu n'aurais pas vu
vincent christophe au classement
ah si julien tué puis il ya environ dix
minutes
à l'ère de détente et détient avec un
homme vous avez des ballons de basket
d'accord merci bonjour ce que vous avez
pas vu vincent n'ont pas aujourd'hui à
demain ya tellement de montparnasse
quartier ça va être compliqué de le
trouver un
[Musique]
jeudi encore magnifique
[Applaudissements]
emile sipa massant la barre un sens
aussi ne les dérangeait pas les avec le
recruteur pour l'équipe de france mini y
passe un test ce matin et vincent le
dernier à passer
ok donc vous allez faire un tour en
course en partant à peu près là bas koné
l'élan chacun d'eux tire en course après
vous récupérez vos remarques
c'est bon c'est parti on va regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super chez free maintenant je peux dire
ce que je ressens pour toi tu es belle
tu est parfaite et je t'aime à moi aussi
je t'aime vincent
[Musique]
poussan
[Applaudissements]